well when actually when when Bening he
won and he started to walk over the head
of so many people so many important
people and it this is something that
every it's shown everywhere at any time
because it was really something very
very funny and beautiful the triumph of
of happiness what was very nice was
beautiful and also because Fellini
he was speaking to his wife who was in
the in the audience and he said just
look at her because now she's going to
cry and she was crying my dad was a big
fan and introduced me to Italian cinema
and therefore Sophia Loren well she made
an incredible impression on me and had
millions and millions of people you know
I just think she had everything she had
sex appeal and guts and great
storytelling she was incredible she is
incredible because I think Hollywood was
still Hollywood then and the stars were
very very big and they were they were
promoted into being big stars and which
doesn't happen today as much they become
celebrities but not stars as as Sophia
Loren as Elizabeth Taylor you know that
kind of stature when I was 9 years old
and she was shooting it started in
Naples the movie with Clark Gable and my
father and Sophia was singing to befall
America and the home was beautiful
you